pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
it's a beautiful day to be alive here in
the Garden of Good and Evil uncle Joey
come to you direct [ __ ] January
30th it's over one more day and the new
year that all that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
gone it's February [ __ ] but it's
really January 30 so what are you gonna
do I've been in this [ __ ] town for 20
goddamn years now with my anniversary
yesterday whoa it's a long [ __ ] 20
years but where he had caught us up I
came here with a suitcase I kind of a
dream and I kind of had something to do
but I had something better to do I had a
[ __ ] mission and Denver I was
supposed to do but I came here instead
and I [ __ ] bang tonight I became a
regular at the store that's all I didn't
go to Montreal these [ __ ] did
invite me nowhere
no your boy Rogan came along started
taking me on the road a little bit even
though I was a [ __ ] savage and I put
the rest into my own [ __ ] hands and
we're here 20 years later you understand
me I'd say that's how easy this is
I wasn't protesting I wasn't worried
about all any outside forces I was
smoking reefer and living my [ __ ]
dream which is to get out of stage broke
poor don't worry about your missions to
get on stage everything else will come
if you get on [ __ ] stage and listen I
was like rich again officer a gentleman
I had nowhere else to go no better than
you I know or else they're gonna [ __ ]
lose it so I did what was in front of me
and here the [ __ ] we are
smoke and breathe for 20 [ __ ] years
later like gentlemen having a good time
understand
sorry about the a beatin I had to get
that out [ __ ] let's fill this
[ __ ] up again this is this
[ __ ] that's the last of the [ __ ]
Russian splurge right there I call
[ __ ] Boonton and haven't put another
shipment out from PO Joey I'm excited I
got a meeting I got a podcast 8 o'clock
tonight Thursday I'm a [ __ ]
Nashville Nashville I'm so [ __ ]
excited I'm ready to [ __ ] go I'm
gonna see my niece I'm gonna go to
[ __ ] Jimmy whatever's hang out with
my man I forget what his [ __ ] name is
now it doesn't matter no names no names
anyway that's it and that's that we got
a good night's sleep I had a great
weekend then I went in jujitsu yesterday
on the Lord's Day that's it I gotta
write I never sent some emails
put some [ __ ] things in the book and
my day is complete all right write your
goals do you 22 [ __ ] push-ups today
polish you dick it's gonna be a good
[ __ ] you know like these people tell
you nothing don't listen to nobody it's
putting your [ __ ] heart that matters
[ __ ] you got a feeling George
miles Devon had a feeling look what
happens always trust your [ __ ]
instincts don't listen to nobody else
trust your [ __ ] instincts
I'm telling you this with a weed poker
in my hand with that the class Joey
where's the class Joey I'm smoking
reflect my [ __ ] beautiful family
ain't no [ __ ] class we just do what
we gotta do I got nothing to hide from
you [ __ ] you got a knife from
me and now since we killed this meal
this time I packed a punch with all
presidential from perennial that's Ted
telling me all weekend I had to go get
another [ __ ] badge and another bag to
put in the [ __ ] safe oh this smells
like the shavings of my phone.i toe
look at that look at that right there
so if you're feeling [ __ ] up today you
don't know what you want to do with your
life write your goals down and give it
20 years you know you look at 20 years
you go [ __ ] 20 years now hey Joey you
can fight for 20 [ __ ] years plus the
six before that plus the [ __ ] 14
before that happen at war my life look
at a [ __ ] face after face that been
true [ __ ] war but you know what I
don't give a [ __ ] I love my family I
love my friends and I move forward
everything else to suck my dick
and that's the most of one lesson of any
[ __ ] Monday it's to keep bushed
don't let him [ __ ] tell you what you
can't do nobody could tell you what you
can't do once you find out what you can
do you're like [ __ ] this is scary this
is all comes from [ __ ] writing and
putting my goals down and just stick it
that's it nice and simple
these [ __ ] beat you look Yeah right
you're right get the [ __ ] out of my face
this is what crack-a-lackin' tight
and then sitting that's that yeah you're
damn funny
you stole now you're ready to rock
hopeful joy but you had the right spot
and now that's it all you need to do is
put your balls and your heart in action
and move forward and let the pieces for
what the [ __ ] they may or it it's Monday
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight 8:00
p.m. be there or be square
mister laughter this is pipe where my
[ __ ] I'm not think of I was to the
finish this [ __ ] pipe be alone
be they'll be square as they say I have
no [ __ ] idea this week took me to
another limit of my [ __ ] mind
telling I like it [ __ ] my eyes they're
real does that little [ __ ] yeah we smoked
the [ __ ] out of my face I smoked this
[ __ ] but that's irrelevant
not that I'm tell these [ __ ]
tonight what you can't do don't even
tell him Shawn and then look him
straight in the face and go it's time to
suck my dick at you yum yum juice okay I
love your [ __ ] - see you tonight
8:00 p.m. be there be square Nashville
Thursday night eight o'clock coming out
then gate like a [ __ ] Savage I love
you guys I have a great day stay black
and keep your eyes open you know I'm
saying people are pissed off [ __ ] the
[ __ ] protesters they black